this is the ultimate surveillance tool
isn't it
absolutely and anonymity isn't even the
worst of our problems the worst of our
problems is the fact that it's going to
be programmable because it is digital it
means the money can be programmed to be
spent in any way in which um the central
bank or the government decides so one of
my particular concerns is the world
economic Forum because they're talking
about implementing a carbon allowance
now this means each individual will be
given a certain amount of um whether
it's credit or whatever it is carbon
that they are allowed to Emit and how do
they Implement that through a central
bank digital currency so if I buy too
many plane tickets or if I buy too much
meat because those things are all
supposedly very bad for the environment
my money when I go to fill up my car
could then be declined so now they're
literally controlling what we can and
can't do with our money it's also
important to realize that the money can
expire so during times of economic
uncertainty central banks love to print
lots and lots of money which causes
inflation and but we could get to a
point where they say instead of printing
money you have to spend at least 10 of
your savings in the next three months if
you don't spend that money in the next
three months then that money is going to
expire and if you can't save money well
then you can't build long-lasting
generational wealth you're always going
to be a slave to the system and you know
I don't think people really understand
the severity of this money is literally
the energy which fuels your life if you
don't have freedom of money you don't
have freedom of anything um you know Dan
I know you talk about um the Second
Amendment you know if they if they don't
need to necessarily get rid of the
Second Amendment but they can just say
they can program your money so that you
can't actually go and buy a gun so again
it really is the uh the most tyrannical
form of um surveillance we will ever see
when they control the money they control
the world
this is why I love your podcast I I
honestly think you're one of the few
people that gets the threat from these
digital currencies I only got about 30
seconds left but just quickly the bank
of England despite being in a massive
inflationary Global crisis has decided
they're going to start printing more
money to a quantitative easing program
this isn't going to stop this inflation
crisis the minute the politics heat up
they just start printing again
absolutely the more debt that we get
into the only way to get out of it is to
continue um printing money they announce
tax cuts they announced that they're
going to be deregulating the market
which caused the crash and as a result
because there's no more um they're not
going to be collecting as much money
because of the tax cuts they're going to
have to borrow more money more debt how
do you solve that printing more money
and inflation so I'm a huge advocate for
Bitcoin
yeah now thanks a lot for your time we
really appreciate it congrats with the
show it's great
thank you Don